hi my name is Ken shots and I'm Neel
Malhotra and we would like to introduce
you to the course on values-based
leadership this course is about how to
lead with our values and implement them
in our organizations gaining a better
understanding of our own value systems
can make us more effective managers and
help us be the kinds of leaders people
want to follow clarifying our value
systems will also help us make better
decisions for the benefit of key
stakeholders such as shareholders
employees customers and society at large
this course will address several key
questions in values-based leadership
should we make decisions based on our
gut intuitions how can we design
organizations to prevent at the
collapses what is the role of companies
in society how can we manage trade-offs
and weigh the consequences of our
actions and how can we engage in
perspective-taking
to build more inclusive and fair
organizations these questions are
complicated and they don't have easy
answers the goal of this course is to
engage with these thorny issues so that
we can better lead with our values by
the end of this course you will clarify
your own values gain a better
understanding of the diversity of
ethical perspectives in business and
learn how to lead and design
organizations to implement your personal
values